hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pray now we just
entered into the crew quarters where
everything is not as it seems the people
here have all been mind controlled say
for one guy who seems to be holed up in
the cafeteria or something like that but
it's not a pretty situation because they
keep turning these people into freakin
bombs I mean that's a horrible way to go
in my opinion but just it's so weird
with the idea that their mind-control to
not only run at other people but then
just have their heads explode oh god oh
come on
saddle saddle saddle saddle Regina
cellars and apparently I can eventually
get the lovely lovely lovely power of
being able to raise things from the dead
I got into secured pharmaceuticals okay
that's good and I just ran out of
inventory space at the opportune time
gonna that get rid of that get rid of
that and we're good to go except over
why does it keep doing that it doesn't
put the spare parts back in the stack
anymore I don't know why externa but
it's causing me a bit of agita here but
I don't need to worry too much about it
so I'm gonna recycled that and in the
next neuro mod I think I'm finally gonna
be able to upgrade my gun so that I can
use the weapon upgrades that I have to
upgrade it further now until that
happens though I'm still gonna be stuck
with what I got new what is over there
hello can I get over there oh it's just
a wall I'm a dummy I wasn't the kind of
guy that just got a side step around
that swoop to do I'm just gonna stare at
it like a goof Mike when you're heading
up to the exec suites to fix the cooling
system there can you bring Morgan these
supplies by the way the code to the grav
shaft has changed it's nine two eight
nine okay and now I can get up to the
executive suites which might mean that
I'm able to get up to my office or not
my office my actual home
[Music]
I have a funny feeling it's gonna look a
little bit like my home that was in the
simulation at the beginning of this game
and even that simulation seems like oh
so long ago now I'm an expert that's
thrown into a world of exploding friends
cuz you got to imagine that this guy
Morgan here if this is Morgan this is
the same guy that knows all these people
so from a cycle Allah hey ow
you're gonna get smacked ah nah nah nah
just slow down there slow your roll and
get whomped Wumpus alright thank you for
being worm okay so I bet I can repair
this guy yes I can because I'm the kind
of guy that has that skill material and
conclusive uh-huh request okay yeah you
keep doing that I'm gonna take all this
garbo man there's a lot of it hello can
I have that thank you
I would have we have here why is it dark
in here there's someone else in need of
my sweet glue am i sweet a fishing blue
oh hey
yellow tulips supply closet that's where
I am right now
think it's gonna be all I gots I just
drink beer straight out of the tap it's
kind of badass I am ooh
all righty then I don't know I'm here
and breathing in whispering but that's
not usually a good sign
I give me in the supply closet please
thank you whoo thank you for some reason
they have a lot of ooh oh no the escape
pods didn't work and we believed it was
intentional those black shapes are
everywhere and everyone we know is dead
or something worth we aren't gonna let
it happen to us to our families we love
you Oh No
oh no they held themselves up in here
and they shot themselves they bolted
these I can't imagine doing that but
this I also can't imagine being in a
situation like this where you would be
faced to see your friends get possessed
by these horrible monstrosity and then
forced to just blow up in front of you I
mean if you think you're gonna die and
and they probably were anyway what other
choice do you have it what is with the
whispering who's doing that oh I don't
think they want to live inside you wait
unless that voice isn't the Typhon
because in a previous documentation they
said the Typhon didn't have any language
so that's the person the echo of the
person talking about the Typhon that
want to live inside us I went to visit
Grace's Brandi had passed from a pair of
plexus and it connect connectome of her
ability to skate still remains unused in
Transtar databanks her parents declined
to be interviewed setting the interviews
with Brandi had done more harm than good
rather than raising awareness of her
condition it had shown the division
Brandi had been one of the first to
discover her new handicap but if neuro
mods are the future what happens to
those unable to use them or afford them
well I think you're okay because it
seems the neuro mod situation kind of
went awry and I don't think we have to
worry about those affecting anybody in
the future because everyone is dead Oh
what is this hello hi oh well hidey
hidey hidey hole we got lovely power
everybody come out from hiding it's okay
now I was
and what is that that's no hey yeah yeah
you're a spiky one why are you so spikes
ow
all right there we go BLAP BLAP BLAP
and BLAP BLAP okay God when I need it
there he Sh alright so carrying on oh
look aah ding dong oh yeah there's
plenty what I can't bust out a sweet
drum solo I'm mashing it as hard as I
can here fine then oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah that's the good stuff
look I sing oh come on
bah I don't sing apparently Morgan might
not even have a voice considering I've
never heard him talk playback audio of
recent events hosted at the yellow to
knit and then background music okay
welcome everyone we've made an amazing
achievement look 12 hours ago we have
broken the eight thousand euro Mart
market hey what the [ __ ] I knew one was
in here I knew I knew it I knew it
improving the quality of life and you
are to be congratulated you are the ones
who made this hole possible and
congratulations to my dear brother
Morgan that was left for earth side to
assist in marketing efforts with the
tranced our board of directors
so that is a toast to trance start to
the neural mark and the future so why
were there whispers and murmurs about
its success if it can't be shared let me
introduce a few of our employees none of
which had any musical talents until
yesterday except chief Choe who I'm told
as a lovely singing voice Oh sky
Danielle whenever you ladies already ah
they got neuromas ah I can see that they
vastly improved I have a I have like a
that became like an objective to listen
to Danielle's song why though oh hi oh
whoa I get to fight you to music do I
hear you
oh yeah miss peach oh okay let me just
heal up here and eat some goobers come
here you come here you lie down
Wow
what the [ __ ] hell you came out of
nowhere time for Agri not a recycler
charge yes please
oh and get a little bit of a lamp in you
there you quotes
all [ __ ] Boston no I don't
okay Chism's why did you what do you not
like music ow oh okay
[Music]
okay
so that wasn't just a song that was
supposed I was like a trap or something
find voice oh oh that makes sense that's
a voice sample that's right that's what
I'm supposed to be doing I completely
forgot about that
okay greater mimic yeah greater mimic I
don't know what I see in the glass but
I'm looking for the body parts of these
guys so I can get some [ __ ] out of them
all right find it oh well I didn't even
know this thing was here man I wish I
would have used it because I didn't even
see it okay
but I got some voice samples and that's
exactly what I needed out of that
situation so ooh transgressions oh that
guy looks a little grizzled all right
whatever she's gonna carry on ooh you
know I want to put you right here and
I'm gonna deploy you and if I have to
repair you I will but I'm not ready just
yet because man I took a walloping in
there they just came at me so quick I
wasn't able to actually like slow them
down or anything it's official type of
material well you're about to have a
whole bunch of Typhon material buddy
boots never mind
apparently that's all gone dead now all
right what do we have here Antonio
frogcast are the summer blockbuster
transgressions did all of his oh no I
reread this he's an amazing man what a
what a stud muffin what an unbelievable
amazing why are we still watching videos
in black and white on film what kind of
degradation of quality of technology is
this we have things that you can shoot
into your brain and give you the false
memories of something with actual skill
but we can't do this that's weird you
know I'm just gonna go back and dump all
my salvaged that I got because it got a
bunch of it I just need another crafting
thing eventually but
oh man I'm full up man I've got so much
garbage I've got like 15 wrenches in my
inventory
no wonder and this and this I don't need
any of that
all right and
and this and the booze and all this
booze oh my god so much booze and then
that should be it I think II think II
thunk along and I should actually keep
my my levels of materials up real high
which means that I'm gonna be able to be
a more deadly an efficient killer as
time goes by but let's see what's in the
theater because I have a funny feeling
we got something made looks flow there
we go
oh hello coin all right thank you for
that come on come on come on let me hit
him point I think that dealt with all
the materials that they had oh
transgressions
Oh oh my it's so amazing okay hada loopy
okay now if I can get in here this
should lead me to some where I need to
go oh what's that
blast Abel's spoink a spoink a blinky
blinky blinky link one oh wait did
someone try to come up here ooh
Recreation Center you say so whether
that was there absolutely nothing in the
theater that I needed I'm gonna guess no
alrighty then I'll take your word for it
but I don't believe it happy birthday
daddy
Oh huh what was it hmm oh I should
probably be smart and set up a trap
Oh oh no you're just a normal person
Oh David don't do it don't do it
ah okay that's a horrible thing to say
man he's literally saying if I find you
were both dead oh that's so sad
hi okay alright then there's no need for
that there's no need for to be a dick
which you do global unity games have
come to a close
the final metal totals for the
participating nations are in limbo amid
allegations of neural enhancements and
next-generation pharmaceutical use every
year these games see previous records
shattered and latest is no exception by
a stunning margin yeah um oh all right
well he's a cat all me me I'm think
there might be some mimics over there
ooh
alrighty then
well be Delpy okay so let's play a
little game here of hide and go [ __ ]
yourself flap nope lap nope no whoa what
is that what are you whoa what the
[ __ ] what
what the hell was that you want to run
that oh ah I've got you I've got you in
my sights I don't know what you are but
I've got you
ooh boink ah you're a poltergoose oh and
you're gone okay all right then well
okay cool that's J to review the
research oh I didn't even know I had
this poltergeists are not a normal part
of Typhon ecology instead they appeared
a result of a rare mutation that occurs
in less than 5% of the Fantom Genesis
cases the poltergeist is also the only
known Typhon to possess the ability to
remember themselves invisible
undetectable even to psycho scopes
scanning but I just scanned it the exact
mechanisms is unknown at this time as
their limited numbers make adequate
study difficult weak to fire well if
only I had a goddamn fire stick also
known as a flamethrower that's what I
meant to say alright there's your corpse
got tossed all the way over here so
there weren't actually there weren't
actually mimics over here there was just
a whole bunch of bold sweet alright
whatever you say I believe you
sure alright okay I'm trusting you for
now and I'm gonna carry on trying to
look for another voice sugar recording
somewhere oh I've got landmarks telling
me where to go I don't even need to do
this huh ah [ __ ] sky star you rang
such a douche such a big old douche I'll
take that I won't take that I'll take
this remember blind ogres can call 400
they were playing dungeons and organs oh
that would all my god that's so cool
oh I love Dungeons & Dragons oh I'm so
good
ah fatal fortress oh that's cool
and sad all they oh look at that Roslin
Swift
oh what a cool name Oh captain stab
fellow oh what a good guy Oh stab
fellows treasure map Oh
stab fellow has vanished into the
darkness beyond the tower door the only
sign of him is his blood trail but as
you watch the flags don't seem to drink
in the blood the cracks glistening red
Jesus Christ on a stick Abigail don't be
such a baby
we either head through the door forget
that it's a state or warrior unless you
can handle the entire pack of rat men Oh
spell list wonder we don't have much
choice Elias
sorry stabbed fellow captain stabbed
fellow can I answer hell no you hear I'm
so into this all right let me light a
torch hey guys sorry I'm late
stationwide OS upgrade had told
Bellamy's Han through the whole process
Abby do you have my character sheet you
made it
yes right here what they not want him
there a horde and baffle flag turrets oh
man oh but I got it I got a voice sample
which is super weird but super cool I
didn't even realize that it was gonna be
about that oh that's so cool though all
right I gotta get to these other places
and quick and without dying
all right so liddy DD what do we have
here
hello intruder please help me someone's
trying to enter my room I have nowhere
to hide ooh seriously my quarters have
no view of space no vent window at all
huh not sparkling wine onboard talos but
I assure you the flat piss your cup
Sears delivered wow these guys are a
bunch of uppity [ __ ] okay 99 zero
for the fitness code and I don't have a
code for this but I do have hacking
skills to get in the mailroom oh wow
okay wait can i no I can't
what the hell how do they expect me to
do this I mean obviously I'm full of
skill and vim and vigor and I'm able to
do it really easily but oh Jesus are you
kidding me Oh No
yeah I got the wrong button ow
why did you have to zap me now is this
insulting oh my god
are you kidding me this is not a level
two this is level who knows what the
[ __ ] what level of this is ah skid Elise
CAD Lee okay so really badly that's
easier your gosh-darn douche nozzle with
your gosh-darn goobie Gabor's and weirdo
Wampus okay I'm gonna take this yes
please and that oh yes please oh yes
please I already had the med kit
fabrication plan so I don't know what
they were talking about but I'll take it
nonetheless anything in his box push key
anything in this box boy whose key no
alright then I and with that being said
not that I'm going to go here and that
means insecurity or is it an engineer oh
I need one more ah for both the bum a
bunch of [ __ ] alright so I'm gonna
go to these different places and
hopefully I'll be able to get these
voice mods
oh okay just crew cabins alright that I
finally stopped insta weirdo you freakin
weirdo oh hi dead person okay alright
then dole K Oh feels weird just going
into someone's habitation hi I'm
Matthias uh-oh watch it twitch
okay I already had that again they're
giving me the same thing over and over
again that that I guess I'm being
relatively thorough and maybe they're
just doing it as a backup to be able to
get more stuff later but alright that's
everything in here apparently excuse you
who's whispering over here huh why is
there a sticky note hey you've
apparently misplaced your transcribe
again just wanted to know I still have
some of your stuff in my room don't know
if you want it back call me or something
Abbi wait is this oh so it's an Abby's
room nationally I know you don't
whoops sorry that's not what I meant to
do whoa Oh zombies you freakin douche
this is ivy you never go got him dead
just a slow burn on amale's just land on
the floor taking it
all right fine transcribe check theater
get my stuff from Abbey's cabin finished
draft of apology letter pull head outta
facts prioritize relationships over work
oh good to-do list I don't think you got
to any of those but I do got to go over
to Abby's place so let's see dr. goo
Daniel my workstation said that it was
time to update my password I want to
know if it was okay to use Kublai Khan
and whether that fits your requirements
for starters if you have any more
questions about password please email
the IT department second you should
never type your password into an email
oh boy
dummy all right I'm pulling a late shift
on the bridge tonight and I left my
transcribe in my pod could I convince
you to bring it for me on your way to
deep storage I have some ideas for make
our uniforms a little less pop star for
a demonstration Oh a little more pop
star oh that's right
okay each of you should have a map
fragment by now I managed to hand them
to some of you in person
others wolf I thought I found I did find
Zachary West map I don't know if I have
time for up okay I found a bunch of
people's maps apparently didn't know I
did that but I dude it out here's Daniel
shows tracking bracelet it's not at all
useful for me oh I can fix this
hello are you recording this join
transcribes are fun they are not it's
like mental scrapbooking you both save
the moments that matter well I got some
more of her voice I think and that means
as soon as it tells me yeah I'm at 60%
which is not exactly where I need to be
oh here we go
crown verse Asian it's a day it sounded
serious so I wanted to shut my
transcribe off so okay so you're asking
me if it's okay to record our game on
the transcribes yes I know using the
memory it's not right I can't be having
this conversation oh I'm so sorry I'm
gonna lose my job for even talking to
you about this what what exactly what
you're going to do is have dinner with
me what you say what a lot when you
should say yes yes see all settled
don't worry about the transcribes it's
not against regulation so are you gonna
invite me to this game or not uh but
there's only 70% one I get more out of a
song than that a song I listen to while
I'm fighting nah boy boring okay another
fictional story over there I'll take
these new Abbi sometimes the word come
running out of your mouth and you want
to catch them all but it's they're late
they're out okay see I love felt more
personal to write you know but still
nice terrifying strata apologize burrs
and I know I'm a counter buddy hose
I'm not gonna this that's obvious words
words blah well that didn't go well at
all man you missed the trash can - miss
- you leaving your character sheet here
but I have a spare in case you don't
make it back before the game don't worry
looks great see at the rec center huh Oh
Malinda shadow corner oh oh so romantic
bunch of baloney
right we're going here I just need to
find a few more samples
this is Abigail's cabin is this what I'm
looking for yellow tulip we had that we
already did that one so we know about
that ooh
I can hack it though whoo Dooley where
am i oh I'm far away but I'm still
better at this than you not talking
about you guys out there I'm sure you're
way better than this man I am all right
I got what I needed let's see uh I don't
think there's a drill do you feel the
vibration oh wait treasure hunt I don't
care about that
come find me Emma at the fitness center
ah okay so I need to go to that please
be there please
are you okay what huh oh sorry I forgot
that that's bound to my right mouse but
it's very easy to do that and it's
really like I'm sorry it just goes off
and I have no control over it whatsoever
I'm sorry
anyway hidden treasure oh that's for the
treasure map oh man I wish I had more
time for that one okay pull castor
ammunition okay I can do that ooh here
we go with the great Alex you today my
brother
oh I'm sorry's with no resolution
ah even Morgan it's like a tradition you
family sorry that's a little yes
insincere as a Danielle Show apology no
no I'm not saying working with them as
easy but did you just compare me to him
to that arrogant sack of [ __ ] Danielle
this has to stop
you're right get out we're done
Danielle I said get out Daniel oh boy
well oh wait Abigail oh did I do it
no no no I'm only at 80% so we got a
little bit to go and we need to go to
the fitness center for some reason hello
where's this that's another bathroom
oh no they're always haunted they're
always haunted bill if you're injured or
sick you can get a pass otherwise 75
minutes of exercise oh it's another code
to the gym I already had that one hello
hello oh that's weird
okay I'll take that someone was hype
owing up in the bathroom hello oh hello
that's heard no something up speaking
food in here don't know why they thought
that was necessary husky all right fine
then I'm going to the fitness center
right about now funk soul brother
hello these are the habitation pot oh
well all right I'm not gonna get I would
like to go to the fitness center but
okay we're gonna see oh whoa don't pick
me up don't you dare don't you goddamn
dare don't you freaking dare let me see
if I scoop you I don't know if there's
anything to goop is there
I think did I goop you whoa
that don't look good there we go okay
lamb lamb lamb okay whoa well got him
apparently with a lot of Typhon organs
in Stowe which is good for me I suppose
Oh exterior breach everyone died out
there ill so what's the differentiation
between people being in these pods and
people being in the other pods yeah but
not so good ones Oh someone drew a
picture of a Typhon oh that's weird
all righty then anything else in here
that's important that I need not that it
looks like how do people even get up
there do they jump well they're just
really strong here on the station
obviously not if everyone's dead
I find men oh hi speaking of dead this
is officer files Malia I have an
important request it's sensitive though
I need to know I can trust you with her
failings better uh yes of course sir
it's just that normally I can't do
something like that without consent from
chief Eleazar HR and another director
those people report to me
no yeah yes sir I understand I want you
to keep an eye on Annelise Gallegos
where she goes how she keeps visitors
I'll log everything on the security
computer third semi report at the end of
the week yes sir
hmm weird
I'm not even sure if I know what that's
about I mean I've heard about these
things but I just later on the game oh
well there was the mail room key that I
got way too later
don't be anything but that's all I need
for that but man that's weird why would
he be surveilling someone because as far
as I know and as far as I've seen
throughout this game I don't even know
if Alex U is actually a bad guy
you know what I mean I don't know if
he's the bad one he's just kind of a
Oh No
just stay there maybe oh boy oh boy uh
well this is nice but whatever no I got
a treasure map covered in blood
okey i oh no I recycled him but I guess
that was better than them just blowing
up I don't know
trying to reach Abbey but she's not
answering
hey Doc come on please no no Emma uh I
can barely hear you safe
is Abby with you are you okay yes not me
no I want I want I won't do it you can
yeah oh no
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry oh I'm sorry oh
I'm sorry what do they tell them they're
gonna blow up or do they just know from
watching other people do that why why is
that a thing is so horrible
okay I can't reiterate enough how just
freaking horrible that is oh it's awful
oh and why do people have so much [ __ ]
in their lockers oh it's a smorgasbord
of Bowl Oh hate that why does someone
have a gun in their locker oh hi sorry
sorry sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
[Music]
oh I feel bad and what's worse is that
I'm gonna stop feeling bad at some point
maybe I don't know if that's true but no
well all right so I need to find just
one more voice sample I'm pretty sure
just one more and I should be a-ok
unless I want to get in shape
oh it's just an ER there's an Irvine
right here okay good personal training
session executive suites nine to eight
nine I think I already had that treasure
hunt okey dokey okay hunters Bowl Kassar
I already had that Nura mod enhanced
yoga oh how did an aroma just make you
all the sudden flexible weird okay
whatever let's see about something else
though there's someone out there in the
pool area all there's so many oh there's
so many I'm sorry
oh oh hi what if I killed that thing
what if I what happens if I just kill
that thing oh that unlike us oh we so
maybe if I kill that thing will it free
the rest of them
maybe it's it's a long shot but willing
to take it I guess none of those none of
that none of that oh man it's gonna take
a lot of bullets to be able to bring
this bad boy down I could fight it
closer does this thing as a fall off
range I don't know if I have enough
bullets but it's gonna be close
oh it's not gonna be enough is it all
right I'm gonna risk something here bull
ah so close oh baby oh baby okay are
they free
are they free are they dead they just
all fell over they fell over
okay are they they're alive they're
alive they're alive they're just
unconscious that's good that's really
good so I can save them I just have to
kill the Weaver I didn't even know that
that was just a hunch oh my god they're
alive for how long I have no idea but
they're alive that's crazy okay okay now
we're getting somewhere
cuz now I can if I can do something
about this horrible horrible this come
on the block is right there oh it's
right there oh you dick hole oh you
frickin dick hole
oh you dingle donger there we go frickin
dong dinger okay
Jesus Fong you uh you oh come on there
we go
what is this I took saddest weird
flashback to alien isolation which is a
game I haven't thought about in a while
no I don't have enough space for that
but I got a fun there's got to be one
more thing for Danielle around here
somewhere it can't just be all this I
mean I didn't even need to turn those
off if that's the case alright but I
found what I came for I think in the
fitness center so we have that so let me
go over to the cafeteria because that's
where it seems to be got it Oh first let
me go to the Salvi
yeah because wasn't the cafeteria where
that dude was held up maybe man what
would have happened if I would went
straight for the straight for that like
telepath in the middle of the pool like
would I have actually been able to save
them I've got so many suit repair kits
I've got a ridiculous amount get rid of
this this this this ah this extra
Ghana's bulk after that did I pick up a
ranch at some point I don't know but
okay that's good
recycle that and then at some point I
need to reactivate the neural mud uh
crafting system because that broke down
recently stuff that you're giving me the
heebie jeebies okay there we go
disrupter stun gun that something a
little off for you I mean there's not a
lot that these people could have done
anyway when it comes down to being
mind-controlled oh hi something happened
here Oh something happened here oh okay
Oh oh hi oh okay you don't see me do you
damn
Oh psycho shock no sound
wool wool okay I don't have enough ammo
for that to be able to beat it and save
the rest of them so I'm gonna go back
I'm gonna go to a crafting place I don't
know where the nearest one would be whew
oh I don't even know if it's worth it to
save them oh I just really don't know if
it's worth it
uh was it was it was it was it was it
was er utility here that I needed the
area map and then surveillance maybe
surveillance recording maybe that was it
what's their voice in here I got a
container set up this is pretty weird
Quinton I know but if I I don't want to
know I'm doing this as a favor that's
all cargo container three two three two
it's on the other side of cargo bay be
next to the utility tunnel when I was
head chef at the space Institute
no one asked me to conceal food in a
cargo container just go easy on a deal
alright okay I don't know what that was
about
oh all right then whistleblower okay
that's part of the whole deal with oh hi
you came out of ways can I pepper you
just give me one shot just enough to get
you out this way ah [ __ ] there's not
gonna be enough
oh no matter what I do these people are
gonna die unless this guy comes all the
way out here which he may or may not
yeah it sure is isn't it
talking about me oh boy oh boy oh boy I
don't think anything I can oh I don't
think I can do anything for Caleb there
I did some damage to her Oh
oh wow that's too far away sorry sorry
Caleb sorry I'm aware of what they won't
and will not stop doing but he needs to
come back here if he's gonna stop being
a little bit of a baby about it I'm
trying not to kill cable up here this
has the Oh Caleb no think about it
resist resist oh boy
oh boy there's no way I'm gonna be able
to not Oh
which way you going Caleb you don't see
me do ya you don't see me all right I'm
in psionic oh I'm very close to beating
this guy
what the hell hit me I've no idea what
hit whoa oh hi where did you come from
what the [ __ ] Oh Mike what the [ __ ]
was that what you just beat the [ __ ] out
of me just like that well that's a bunch
of baloney well alright then you jackass
fine if you're gonna be like that
alright let me let me get back to where
I just was running away I see okay I see
how you be I don't think I can get who
it is gone far far away you know what
I'm trying to go around you I guess well
let me get my hunters bolts I'm trying
not to I'm trying not to I really really
am trying not to it's almost as old
dad's over there I'm trying to save you
try to save you try to save you I killed
it Paul Ricca dick Oh should fight
before they get close they're puppets
bombs their master is close I kill best
of puppets or both but do it before they
kill you okay no more puppets maybe we
talk well how about we talk now because
I just blew up the big thing because I
figured out what I needed to do here and
that person's dead but this person is
merely unconscious and I've done a good
thing here and I've done real good and
I'm gonna go back here oh hello Caleb
were you important you seem to have a
mark over your head
you were close you're close to blowin
but I somehow saved all of you because
of how much of a goddamn hero I am so
anyway survivor hello oh yeah you're the
guy I'm talking to hello hi
hello oh well this does not bode well
for me but I'm going to go in here
anyway
hello that's me
it's markiplier the one and only I find
that if you're not too satisfied about
it oh that's right I probably shouldn't
go over there ah huh you're unconscious
in your suit what is in your name tab
you hmm and you and you you'll kill this
yourself huh if you want to come in be
safe you go get something of mine
huh okay we know it opens my room ah go
there get my award it's important to me
okay then maybe we talk well I mean I'm
not really here to be you know okay
alright bye then I guess her
conversation is over
I came here for a voice sample and I
apparently got sidetracked with a bunch
of shootin and I thought that maybe I
could just you know get along with my
day and you could be stopped such an
[ __ ] and then maybe you'd know who I
am who I was oh man
God is so well how many of them watched
their friends blow up before even they
were turned into bombs at least I have
the consolation that I've saved some of
them oh oh oh
Fah Fah Fah okay I think that's all the
bodies for now but I haven't found
anything like a transcribe so that I can
get more of a data sample oh also my
webcam went away for a little bit that
it's been doing this weird thing where
it's been freezing recently why do you
have white dude I'll carry you up the
stairs maybe is that what you needed
okay now I'm gonna go to the cabin and
I'm gonna see about that because
apparently that's where I need to go
next because I'm at 90% I'm like right
there but I just don't have everything
that I need I'm gonna just dump off
scrap one more time before I carry on
but I'll get this award and then
hopefully this guy's gonna help me get
the last bit here unless I was somehow
able to do the last bit on my own I
haven't seen the ability to do that just
yet aren't carrying on this is all I've
got so far
Group D I thought I got this
surveillance report I already got it all
I needed to download the report that's
right that's what I needed I forgot to
get died after I died no worry about
flickering station is just working
uh-huh keep going well I mean I've
already been down here I've already seen
the nightmare so I was pretty sure that
I actually already had everything under
control
oh hi whoa ha whoa hi oh you'll
prototype what the hell is going on here
Oh aah ooh ooh all righty then ooh they
were up to some shady dealings ok Lissy
greetings dr. Cayle strep unfortunate
kilo
[Music]
I'm out of glue oh boy all right you
know what I'm gonna lock that door I'm
gonna just lock that all right we're
gonna lock then we're gonna have a nice
time over here as always Eliot will mark
them with the eds thank you for your
patience Babu DejaVu is set in again
retracing steps is going to be a little
harder this time it seems that Muller
staff was not properly recording data so
all the progress they made since the
last department-wide removal is in
jeopardy
we'll need to temper our expectations
wiping the memories of the entire
department as its tremendous setback and
I'm beginning to question the practice
versus the results we've seen we should
revisit the staggered system we
discussed last year get them scheduled
oh that's from Alex ah so there was
something really shady going on here how
did you even sleep you didn't have any
space or whatever work is work I guess
all right let's see what this guy's all
about Oh aye ma'am stop that stop
stop being all kinds of electrocuting
that's really unnecessary
goosh goosh goosh alright fine then
seasons these guys are getting violent
these guys are getting real violent good
thing I got so many health kits it's
almost an unreal amount of health kits
ok so is this the Kochs rep now this
isn't the customer where am I now the
knurl horizon the process doesn't hurt
not at all her smile is radiant her eyes
bright is no hint of Parra plexus eating
at her nerve endings the Olympic medals
lie in our glass cases facing her like
an audience yet I still had my love of
skating the skill felt trapped inside my
head the mods the neuro mods allowed
that skill to be shared with others oh
so these are mappings of other people
these are oh ok that's really
interesting then because these aren't
just you know adaptive to the people
these are literally mappings of savants
of their respective fields and they
Calvin tiered to be scanned at the end
of their lives I think anyway I'm pretty
sure that's the way that goes miss
Goodwin to follow up on the previous
request I was wondering if there'd been
any updates on Gustav Leitner's visit is
it still taking place and if so would it
be possible to get a copy of his
itinerary
I would love a chance to meet him before
the neuro mapping procedure if possible
good thing I didn't have enough hypo
because I almost blasted myself dr. EGH
WA I related your previous request and
we'll see what we can do about that but
there are no guarantees the schedule for
visit oh I've actually seen that before
I read that earlier interesting
orchestrated objective reduction
consciousness is based on non-compatible
quantum processing aha I'm gonna pretend
like I understood that okay there's
another haunted bathroom hello ah okay
interesting all right
fascinating whoo this guy loves food
did you do to that thing Mitchell sounds
like an anti waffle commercial well I
didn't see it as an override per se but
it was just the operators conversation
sequencer they're usually so grim do you
know how many security protocols you
broke well Morgan's said it was alright
even helped me this is an a/b
conversation skillet okay but anyway I
got him that was actually a long lengthy
procedure I'm actually surprised about
that sagging to this one and see what
his emails got oh yeah of course I'm all
the way over here but I'm good at what
I'm doing Rick Oh what have we got here
what were you up to anyway it doesn't
make any sense
oh hello that should be enough to
synthesize Danielle's voice yeah to
spoof the lock on deep storage anyway
yeah also I've been monitoring noetic
field signatures around the station when
I can with humans the signal barely
registers the taifa n-- make a strong
ripple by comparison but with the coral
my instrument readings are erratic I'm
not sure what it means hmm
the sooner we get your arming key the
better yeah to blow this whole place up
that's gonna be a choice at the end of
the game Morgan hey I guess you should
have shifted cafeteria visits or taking
food in your quarters now but why to say
thanks again for the e mode upgrade use
dear skillet now much better don't think
Daniel liked it but hopefully she that
doesn't cause any trouble between you
two
don't be a stranger still plenty of your
favorite snacks in stock just swing on
by whenever you get a breather
appreciate the help will sorry to
contact you during your downtime but
alex has been working through the 4:00
a.m. shift and is put in a food request
at the front desk he says you know what
he likes did you bring his meal to the
executive suites okay alright then weird
back stabbed in the face the star bender
cycle for another day maybe all right I
got your goddamn award let's see what
the hell this thing is gonna do for me
in terms of getting me through
that area but we do have enough to
synthesize the voice yeah he's still
alive yeah uh-huh
what if mu comes back you find it yeah
I'm too Wingo show me okay all right
then I don't know why oh Jesus
this I I think I know what this guy was
doing [ __ ] you're not will Mitchell
though this guy this guy is not will
Mitchell this guy is very clown
something will Mitchell is the guy we
were hearing on the radio after let your
transcripts promised go around beside
entrance will Mitchell was on the
recordings or was that another name that
just looks similar and just happened to
be close I do not remember this guy beam
wait
don't you dare don't you frickin dare
okay all right then those skeezy looks
easy now the beasts they cannot get in
okay but look at this okay why food but
no water
this pressure glitter it is broken
system a demonic kind of until fixed you
can find a replacement port in green'
house I think or I can fix it right why
don't we can wait for rescue okay there
we go I did it
you know what thanks Oh smart one
yeah that's me I open freezer now let
the promis'd lots of dead puppets and
supplies gross
why did you keep them all right skillet
okay this is super weird I'm gonna take
a look at this when puppets can get in
explode like bomb no no
I won't fight what I didn't do anything
what did I do
what what the [ __ ] are you talking about
what happened what what what what what
what what he what are you doing what
what the [ __ ] happened
he just started freaking out and running
all over the place where are you going
[Music]
I am so confused I didn't do a god I
didn't even touch him I wasn't even near
him I wasn't anywhere close ok ah oh boy
I'm still in deep storage I don't know
why you won't be chris is a B I hope
you're safe if things get bad I'll
jettison a data vault and space walk
along the hole come to the fitness
center and bang on the window by the
pool I should feel the vibration and ABI
please don't take any chances all right
I be safe
Wow well wait Daniel show she's
essentially bang on the Daniel is alive
Oh God wait yeah she's alive oh holy
[ __ ] she's alive Wade that just dawned
on me like why this she's alive
cooking with cauliflower I've already
read that one oddly enough all right
what is it what is the obsession with
eel suspicious meat oh good and there
was will Mitchell's tracking bracelet
that's right
cuz this isn't will Mitchell I know that
for a fact
I was already right there with them so
anyway we've got another mystery
apparently Danielle's alive and I have
to give her the sad news that ABI is
dead but either way that's all the time
I got for this episode so thank you
everybody so much for watching hope you
enjoy it let me know how i'm doing the
comments below as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
[Music]